alireza just an incredible day for you
you scored quite well six and a half out
of nine how are you feeling right now
assess your day for us yeah
um for sure it was a
good day but I was expecting like more
maybe like
um I guess Robert I lost a very bad game
and after that it was not I didn't I was
not in a good mood so
but yeah
um of course now for second is the spot
is open so we have to fight for that and
it's good for the whole GCT
standing because Magnus is stealing the
points yeah Magnus is not playing so
it's okay
okay well let's talk about this game
against uh Yan because I think by the
way you are always around 2 900 coming
into this event and throughout the day
did you know that was that in the back
of your mind as well no 2 900 is not the
goal for me another goal okay but I
don't know now I think maybe I dropped a
lot of points probably unclear I think
yeah I think it's about even
um because everybody else is quite high
rated but Magnus is probably number one
now probably after night he was down 50
points he was yeah he was he was
probably his number let's talk about
this game uh between yourself and Nepal
because you said this was perhaps your
favorite one he missed okay not this
very special game but he messed up the
opening and it was very convincing mean
this was the
line that he confused because now my
Bishop goes to B6 and
um I'm better here so yeah but against
Magnus he played Queen A5 against me it
doesn't I never saw this move
um
played Queen A5 here and I I was
I played C3 and E5 here I couldn't find
how to proceed here I don't I wanted to
go attacking what it backlashed there
yeah and yeah I think right now you have
to like stay put maybe play something
like Bishop D2 or 92 92 yeah computers I
pushed before
yeah what was the mindset going into
this one you really wanted to stop it he
was already on a streak you wanted to
catch yeah I lost only one game before
that also like I was five out of six six
out of seven so we were both in good
shape but yeah he was in better shape
even than me so yeah and that was uh
after B4 it's already very difficult to
recover because you have too many
weaknesses are going into the final day
you are four points and a half behind
Magnus what what is your mindset are you
still playing for a win are you still
hoping for that or are you playing for
second place right now
just playing her second place
it's ridiculous to think about first
place because even Magnus loses four
games I'm down if I win four mag this
list four then I'm down hops
it doesn't make sense to play
for first but second is a good result I
think
if I manage to get it but it's tough
Fabiano is playing good and Jan also so
we'll see definitely a big race tomorrow
to the Finish Line we'll let you go get
some rest get ready for tomorrow and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you Christian thank you